سنه كامله تمر على بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا حملت معها الكثير من الاحداث
والتداعيات التي جاءت تباعا مع تحول
الازمه لحرب بالوكاله بين لاعبي العالم
الكبار
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه على حد تعبير
الكرملين خلفت تغييرات عميقه في اوروبا
وازمات جاءت تباعا بدايه من الطاقه الغذاء
والامن صحيفه التلغراف طرحت اربعه
سيناريوهات توضح بالتفصيل كيف يمكن ان
تنتهي حرب بوتين ضد اوكرانيا
السيناريو الاول يطرح فكره تحول الصراع
الحاصل الى حرب ابديه قد تستمر لشهور او
سنوات طويله يخوض فيها الطرفان حرب
استنزاف مديده تتارجح بين المكاسب تاره
والخسائر تاره اخرى دون الاستسلام اما
السيناريو الثاني فيطرح فكره وقف اراقه
الدماء اذا اتفقت طرفان على وقف اط النار
الذي من شانه ان يجمد الوضع السياسي
والاقليميه الراهن حيث ان هذه الخطوه
ستقلل العبء الاجماليه على عاتق المدنيين
في اوكرانيا غير انها لن تحل الاسباب
الاستراتيجيه الكامنه وراء الصراع
السيناريو الثالث يطرح فكره الوحده
الروسيه حيث يمكن للهجمات المضاده الروسيه
الناجحه في دومباس والتدمير المستمر للبنى
التحتيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا ان تمكن
موسكو من تعزيز مكاسبها الاقليميه على
الاقل فيما يتعلق بالاقاليم الاوكرانيه
الاربعه التي تم ضمها
السيناريو الرابع يطرح فكره النصر
الاوكراني في الميدان من خلال اجبار
القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب الى المواقع
التي كانت تنتشر فيها قبل بدايه الحرب
ويكون من خلال شن اوكرانيا هجمات مضاده
وبتحويل جيشها من قوه دفاعيه الى قوه
هجوميه
هذه السيناريوهات تقابلها تطورات ميدانيه
متسارعه في اقليم دومباس معارك عنيفه دون
تغيير كبير في الخريطه لكن ربما تتغير هذه
الخريطه قريبا بحلول فصل الربيع